[Musique]
les images sont toujours les mêmes des
récoltes brûlées dans les champs
carcasse d'animaux morts de soifs et
après la perte du bétail la suite
implacable les petits-enfants souffrent
rapidement de malnutrition sévère
d'autres images trop familières une
clinique de brousse débordée les enfants
sont pesés les bras trop maigres mesurés
selon les résultats la famille aura
droit ou pas au rations de nourriture de
plus en plus limitée les organismes
d'aide sur le terrain manque de
ressources faute de
donsomalie dit-il et sur le point de
devenir réalité si on ne réagit pas
immédiatement selon le programme
alimentaire mondial
828 millions de personnes dans le monde
se couchent chaque soir le ventre vide
ses 25% de plus que l'an dernier
le réchauffement de la planète a
accéléré le cycle du sécheresse qui
surviennent maintenant aux cinq camps
parfois même aux deux ans plutôt qu'au
20 ans avant et elles sont souvent
suivies par des inondations
dévastatrices les conflits armés les
confinements de la pandémie et
l'inflation des derniers mois ont aussi
fragilisé des populations déjà
vulnérables
ce garçon de 3 ans les membres enflé un
signe de malnutrition sévère sa maman
craint de perdre un troisième enfant une
mère ne s'habitue pas à voir un de ses
enfants mourir de faim à petit feu ici
pour nous ces images sont identiques à
celles de la dernière famine la douleur
des victimes elle n'est pas la même
parce que les souffrances s'accumulent
d'une crise à l'autre
sont de moins en moins capables de
réagir au choc chaque crise fait des
ravages ils n'ont pas eu le temps de
s'en remettre qu'une autre catastrophe
survient et des crises alimentaires il
n'y en a jamais eu autant les
populations mangent à peine un repas par
jour dans 53 pays en Asie l'Afghanistan
le Pakistan le Bangladesh et le Myanmar
sont sur la liste des pays en crise au
Moyen-Orient il y a la Syrie et le Yémen
en Amérique ha le Guatemala le Honduras
El Salvador et on a faim dans une grande
majorité de pays africains en
particulier ceux qui subissent des
conflits ou des attentats djihadistes
[Musique]
on applaudit ici la libération au début
du mois de 66 femmes et enfants qui
avaient été kidnappées par un groupe de
combattants islamistes au Burkina Faso
le petit pays est pris en otage par des
groupes armés qui se battent pour le
contrôle de trafic de drogue de migrants
et d'otages
le Burkinabè aujourd'hui c'est
véritablement la question sécuritaire
c'est une question qui est venue les
déstabiliser c'est une question qui les
empêche aujourd'hui de vivre
convenablement
Ousmane Diallo s'occupe des programmes
d'Oxfam Québec au Burkina Faso au Mali
et au Niger trois pays qui s'enlisent
dans une crise sécuritaire et
humanitaire sans précédent ces
populations qui vivent toujours en
grande majorité d'une agriculture de
subsistance ne peuvent plus cultiver
leurs champs le contexte sécuritaire ne
leur permet pas de travailler ces
personnes sont exposées à la famille ces
personnes sont exposées à la souffrance
de façon continue
[Applaudissements]
on voit les gens par la petite vie
normale on peut dire et puis
sans avertissement il peut y avoir des
détentions qui vont éclater souvent
c'est même pas entre qui parce puis on
le voit sur les bâtiments parfois
criblés de trous de balle nous avons
rencontré Guillaume bayardjo l'automne
dernier alors qu'il revenait d'une
mission au Yémen
Québec a des projets pour aider
l'approvisionnement en nous la guerre
qui perdure depuis 8 ans dans ce pays a
engendré une famine en passe de devenir
selon l'ONU la plus grave que l'humanité
est connue depuis un siècle la
nourriture il y en a mais les gens n'ont
plus les moyens pour se payer ces
aliments là entre autres par la
dépréciation de la devise locale entre
autres par
les enjeux économiques au niveau de
l'emploi puis maintenant la raison
d'enjeux sécuritaire ces gens-là n'ont
plus accès à trouver facilement du
travail
il cause les famines mais l'extrême
pauvreté des paysans qui n'ont que leur
récolte pour survivre cette pauvreté a
explosé depuis la pandémie de covid 345
millions de personnes en majorité des
enfants risque de mourir de faim cette
année un chiffre qui a presque triplé
depuis 2019